je m'appelle manon moynier je suis
chevrières sur la commune de saint nom
la bretèche j'ai rejoint l'exploitation
familiale depuis deux ans
donc j'ai 40 chèvres adultes ici avec un
petit j'ai deux races de chèvre du coup
les chèvres blanches céder sa laine et
les marans et des alpes il donc deux
races différentes une qui fait du lait
plus gras et une qui fait plus de la
mine
alors moi je n'étais pas du tout dans le
métier j'ai une famille d'agriculteurs m
agriculteurs depuis quatre générations à
famille moi je suis issu du
médico-social j'étais l'éducatrice je
m'occupais de personnes autistes et puis
j'ai arrêté du coup pour venir m'occuper
des chèvres qu'il n'y avait pas ici de
chèvres mais je devais un jour reprendre
l'exploitation familiale donc j'ai
cherché à quelque chose qui me plairait
et j'ai fait un stage avec des chaises
et ça m'a vraiment plu puisque c'est les
animaux très proche de l'homme
j'ai fait un bac pro à distance pendant
mon travail d'éducatrice pour pas
arrêter de travailler et puis j'ai
arrêté de travailler le jour où les
chèvres sont arrivés sur l'exploitation
donc en septembre 2020
du coup là c'est la future chèvrerie qui
sera fini d'être construite on espère
avant l'été où on pourrait accueillir du
coup les 200 chefs parce qu'à terme je
vais accueillir 200 chèvres voilà avec à
gauche les modules blanc c'est l'atelier
de transformation en glace et en fromage
et la future boutique sur le même site
comme on accueille aussi beaucoup de
gens il ya une ferme pédagogique qui est
en train de se construire sur le terrain
pour l'accueil de groupes en situation
de handicap mais aussi de public en
général
[Musique]
avec le lait des chèvres je transforme
en glace exclusivement et puis bientôt
en fromage
ça c'est la machine de glace
qui pasteurisé de l'est et qu'ils ont
mais le mélange de dans une fois que
c'est fait ça descend ça turbine grâce à
l'air ça donne une texture de glace ça
sort un peu comme une glace à
l'italienne et ensuite on le moule soual
en dépôt dans des petits pots soit on
peut en faire comme l'un des eskimos
[Musique]
la glace sous les chefs n'a pas debout
disney que lé moins grasse on retrouvera
pas l'odeur du fromage de chèvre par
exemple
là on a de la glace à la noisette donc
c'est moi qui fais moi même ma purée
noisette là il ya de la glace au miel
c'est du miel local de crespières des
deux gourmands de la biscuiterie
miellerie les deux gourmands
c'est très important de discuter avec
les gens de leur présenter ce qu'est
l'élevage comment s'occupe de nos
animaux les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer ou les moments de bonheur
qu'on croise j'aime partager avec les
gens donc je veux que ça reste important
et je veux je veux créer un emploi
protégé aussi c'est quelque chose de
très important qui me avec mon ancien
métier aussi